un paso más cerca de reunirse con sus
familias 144 soldados ucranianos son
trasladados en bus a la región de
zaporiya según kiev los combatientes
fueron liberados el miércoles en el
mayor intercambio de prisioneros con
Rusia desde el comienzo de la guerra un
momento de alivio para los que creían
que nunca saldrían del cautiverio
Estoy muy emocionado pero el viaje fue
muy difícil porque era uno de los
numerosos intentos Para volver a casa
según las autoridades ucranianas la
mayoría de los soldados estaban
gravemente heridos lesiones de balas
traumas por explosiones quemaduras y
amputaciones cientos más seguirían en
manos de Rusia y de los separatistas Pro
Moscú pero se desconoce su paradero
me gustaría pedir a nuestras autoridades
que pongan todo su empeño en traer de
vuelta a todos estos chicos que siguen
prisioneros gracias a ellos a los que
han salido a luchar ganaremos esta
guerra
el presidente ucraniano
bolodimirselenski celebró la liberación
de los militares y afirmó que la mayoría
habían defendido la planta de asoftal en
mariucal junto con civiles los
combatientes se habían refugiado en los
túneles subterráneos de la instalación
durante semanas bajo condiciones
insalubres con poca comida y agua
Moscú no hizo ningún comentario sobre el
intercambio pero el líder del
autoproclamada República Popular de
donetsk en el este de Ucrania confirmó
que 144 soldados habían sido liberados
incluidos sus combatientes y los del
ejército ruso